there he is the popular tim calshaw how
are you tim
hey dad how are we doing is that how
this works your hair looks good
oh thank you yeah thank you it's early
in the morning to
to look this good but it's it's very
soft as you know
do you wake up and it looks like that
pretty much
pretty much it it's it's there's not a
lot of variety
there's not a lot of fluctuation you're
like jimmy johnson
i don't know about his his i think that
helmet that he puts out there that takes
some work
that takes a lot of ozone layers to
destroy to get that thing in shape
uh all right so if you wrote a column at
halftime
of the cowboys against the falcons what
would you have what would you have said
well i'm so glad you asked because so
many of our great columns
end up not in print because of a
shocking change at the end of the game
and i i used one paragraph of this but i
was really going to get into 20 years
ago
dave campo's debut was against the
eagles that was the pickle juice game
remember that game 109 degrees at texas
stadium
eagles open with an on-site kick just
beat the hell out of him injured troy
injured galloway
whole season went up in flames this was
different from that
but i was wondering if a how mike
mccarthy could make
such a poor home debut every player on
the team
is fumbling they look completely
unprepared they run two horrible fake
punts
nobody goes o for two in fake punts
and they did and yet because of a lot of
things
a little bit of their credit a little
bit of zero lions credit
and a lot of atlanta falcons they end up
winning the game 40 to 39.
all right that i don't know what cowboy
fans feel like
today because okay now you're back down
to earth you got the win you shouldn't
have gotten the win it was incredible
and now you go to seattle do you have
any idea what kind of team dallas has
this year
you know i i still think they're pretty
good i think the fumbles are
a flukish thing zeke is not a big
fumbler
dak had fumbling issues two years ago
not not so bad of late and who knows if
dalton schultz i mean
is he a fumbler we don't really know
he's he's never really handled the
footballer but i mean i think the
offense is going to pile up a ton of
yards and score some
but the defense really against the rams
wasn't very good they gave up a lot of
yards
this time because of the fumbles they
gave up points quickly
but they i mean i think atlanta could
have if atlanta wanted to just come in
and throw the ball
and i don't know why they did they were
determined to see how many times
they could run todd gurley into the
middle of the line for three yards
they had the cowboys secondary outmanned
and they stayed away from they still
ryan threw for four touchdowns and
julio dropped another one so i think the
cowboys have real concerns
against russell wilson and those
receivers having said that
seattle's last in the league in defense
right now their defense is getting
shredded
and they just lost bruce irvin and they
lost uh you know a guy in the secondary
so i mean i think that's a that's kind
of a slugfest uh
sunday afternoon i think people feel
like okay this cowboys team
hasn't shown it's better than last year
it's still pretty good we need to see
more
when you watch that on sidekick what do
you see
um you know initially i i i'm watching
it and i just don't think it's going to
go
10 yards if you watch it and we've all
watched it 20 times now
but by the time it gets to the numbers
the 40 it's not even gone the full five
yards it's got to go five more yards
and all of a sudden it makes a it makes
a right turn into the falcons
and you just don't know like why aren't
they falling on it
and i think i was thinking that i know i
think that afterwards but i think i was
thinking
the falcons can follow this ball they
don't have to wait for 10 yards
once it goes to 10 yards it's a
free-for-all so you don't want to just
stand there like it's
going down the third baseline and you
hope it goes foul
because if it goes fair you're screwed
and and they were screwed and so
you know uh dan quinn said afterwards
the players know the rules
i have very little doubt that the
players don't know them they there's
and i don't know if dallas's players
knew the rules either they don't because
cj goodwin the guy who recovered it said
see with the new rule they can't touch
it for 10 yards
okay cj great recovery but you don't
know the rules either
i was also wondering about this tim with
the pitch of the football field
so it's usually higher in the middle of
the field than it pitches down you know
you know when there's rain that they
they always had those football fields
like i don't know what dallas's playing
surface is like but i was wondering
about that
i didn't know if the ball was going to
go 10 yards but i i didn't know if it's
it's going downhill a little bit if
there's a pitch
in that uh in that football field i
think most of the fields now that i
think about don't have as much of a
crown as they used to
when you and i used to patrol the
sidelines in the 80s and the
90s uh but they still have a little
and so it might have been going a little
bit downhill you know i i think it's a
little bit of a
it's a great kick by zeroline it's a
little bit of a fluke that it it's
rolling and rolling and rolling and then
all of a sudden it goes this way which
you need it to do
it's incredible to his credit he's he's
worked on it he said
he and johnny hecker used to play around
with the rams
and practice it because they knew with
the new rules you got to do something
different than you know the other
on-side kicks today aren't working
does dak just take it that dvd of the
game and then just slide it under jerry
jones's door
with his performance after the fumble
yeah because i mean
it looked like the first three or four
possessions hell they're not even gonna
be able to get the ball
you know the cowboys had two tackles
missing the falcons were coming at him
dax getting hit he's been sacked he's
fumbled he's
throwing a couple balls in the dirt and
uh to go from that
to uh you know 450 yards
and and hitting all the right throws
but i mean i think jerry has a stack of
those dvds now so
so i don't know what it is that's going
to bring
you know we mostly don't have to write
about it and talk too much about it for
another few months but
you do wonder you know if uh if
you know trevor lawrence will have his
second contract before dak gets
[Laughter]
monday night football i know that we i'd
like to focus on the negative here and
it feels like
the national narrative is drew brees
question mark do you or did you take
that away from last night's game that
the saints and drew brees
i want to point out very quickly that
you know the dallas stars were playing
the uh the uh tampa bay lightning at the
same time last night
and you and i once once traveled the nhl
circuit yes we did during the stanley
cup
finals and such my
no i i did watch a fair amount of the
game and i watched some of the throws
people are concerned about i think i
think the obvious thing we have all
found out
for sure is that michael thomas isn't
just a guy who
who benefits from drew brees that is a
two-way street
and and without that street um yeah i
mean he
i i don't know if he's going to play
that poorly all the time
but but it it was a little bit more
alarming than i expected for sure
what is the storyline after two weeks
that will still be there in 10 weeks
the surprising storyline that will still
be there in 10 weeks
is that the arizona cardinals are really
good and kyla murray is making a run at
at some of these other quarterbacks for
for mvp
the the more solid story is that
baltimore is going to beat kansas city
this week and establish that they
have picked up they've taken all the
debris from losing that game against
tennessee
made themselves a better team and that
they look unstoppable
yeah but it you know we look at
baltimore the way we do the dodgers
like we don't care what you do during
the regular season we want to know
what you're going to do when you get to
the postseason but that i mean the
dodgers have had a lot of failures the
baltimore's had
one that matters for this club so
lamar i mean well i mean you can say
lamar jackson the year before
but i mean that team wasn't ready and
the chargers chargers took advantage of
it yeah
i mean i guess you can but i i think
it's a little too soon to
to put them to put them there well i
picked them to win the super bowl so i i
i i that means we'll be watching
somebody
no i had kansas city winning last year
did you uh
yeah okay yeah but okay yeah i think i
had
kansas city against the uh eagles
i had the eagles and but it wasn't
kansas city i don't remember
yeah we probably had the chargers or
something yeah you know the nfc east
though
this will help the cowboys oh it's
it's sad just stacked top to bottom
no just it's stacked bottom to bottom
it is so bad i mean two and six this
year
uh i think they were 24 and 40 last year
it is just i mean the cowboys again if
they go nine and seven though
they might walk away with it well i have
no idea the eagles
they always get injuries but i had no
idea they'd look like this are you one
around the horn today
i am on tomorrow dan and it might be i
don't know if i can say this
on the air it might be the last one
for me from home because we might be in
studios
sometime soon wow so this is a breaking
story
that i you know i don't know if i'm
allowed to break that but i kind of feel
like i just did
but schefter is going to take credit for
that
she will he will jump on it and he'll
get 8
000 likes around the horn moving to
studio
8 000 likes i got to get tony reality
out of his house
yeah and you got to get him a haircut
yes he's a mess you know he looks like a
madman
and uh it's it's just it hasn't gone
well for the realities
well uh good luck tomorrow we'll be
watching as always
thank you and we always appreciate the
shout outs i might wear this same shirt
i might give it a little tug here
oh sorry what you're gonna do little
shout out oh
now we're going to watch now we're going
to watch thank you tim
thank you danny that's tim callashaw
dallas morning news columnist espn
around the horn panelist
dallas stars apologist as well